[Music]
uh
i think it's okay to start my analysis
of guillermo del toro's
pan's labyrinth with a spoiler ophelia
the main character
she dies at the end i feel fine doing
that because del toro does the exact
same
thing with his movie the first shot of
pan's labyrinth
is the ending and it's also the first
way in which del toro
complicates that ending but before we
get into that a few things about
fairy tales for most of us the
authoritative source for fairy tales
is walt disney and that's no accident
disney set out to claim that authority
when he made films like snow white
cinderella or sleeping beauty by
adapting folk tales in the public domain
and copyrighting the adaptations still
because film was a relatively
new medium capturing the authority he
wanted required disney
to remain faithful to the original
versions of these stories
popularized by charles perrault and the
brothers grimm
he made the transition from print to
cinema as smooth as possible for the
audience even going so far as to begin
his movies
with the opening of a book disney was
smart
his films are now regarded as classics
and yet by remaining so
faithful to the story's 19th century
antecedents
he inherited and furthered their 19th
century
morality a conservative patriarchal
value system in which
the prince always comes to save the
helpless heroine
a value system that was antiquated even
then in this way
disney limited the kinds of things a
fairy tale
can do in pan's labyrinth guillermo del
toro attempts
to explode these limitations and he does
so by recontextualizing these stories
instead of pulling from a single
authoritative source del toro pulls from
a
huge number of sources giving none
precedence over the others
and letting them all play against one
another to create meaning
the film tells the story of the little
girl ophelia and her mother carmen as
they go to live
with the hyper fascist captain vidal
five years after the spanish civil war
vidal is trying to snuff out the last
remnants of rebellion in the mountains
awaiting his child's birth by carmen
while ophelia becomes ensnared in a
magical quest after a fawn
tells her that she is the lost princess
of an underground realm
from here the story spins out into two
parallel
narratives the magical quest and the
political drama
crucially neither of these narratives
becomes reducible
to the other del toro makes a point of
this by entwining them in ways that
makes any
totalizing explanation problematic at
the end of the film for example we get
what seems to be the nail in the coffin
for the magical quest the doll
approaches ophelia speaking with the
fawn and when the camera cuts to his
point of view
the fawn is not there this appears to be
solid evidence for those who read
ophelia's quest
as a coping mechanism for her sad life
but if we back up we can see how del
toro complicates that reading by
remembering that vidal
has just been drugged with a heavy dose
of sleeping medication
in other stories drug-induced
hallucinations are used to explain away
why people see the supernatural
but in pan's labyrinth it's the opposite
del toro
uses the device to destabilize our trust
in captain vidal's point of view
here and elsewhere the film refuses to
obey our desire
for an all-encompassing explanation of
course disobedience
is a major theme in this film whereas in
many fairy tales disobedience is the act
that sets the story in motion
here disobedience is framed as a vital
and important quality
there's the disobedience of the rebels
who seek to free spain from the grip of
fascism the disobedience of mercedes who
works with the rebels and of course the
disobedience of ophelia who
by turns questions and disregards the
commands of her mother
the captain and the fawn but the most
effective and i think
impressive disobedience here is that
displayed within the very
text of the movie and this is where del
toro's intense
referencing comes into play the name of
the game here
is multiplicity undermining a single
authoritarian master narrative like
those championed by vidal and fascism in
general
by setting up a network of intertexts
that make
meaning a matter of choice think of all
the linking references
in the paleman scene for example you
have the ogre himself nodding to other
child eating ogres and other mythologies
like krampus
it also refers to the greek titan kronos
who devoured his god children in order
to like
fascist spain keep the young from
replacing them
and coming into their own also it should
be noted that kronos is the title of del
toro's first film one of many things
that links
his body of work together the table
itself links back to the banquet scene
earlier in the film putting the pale man
in the same position as vidal
who will go on to kill a child the pile
of shoes link forward and will go on to
recontextualize ophelia's red shoes
itself a link to the wizard of oz and
the 1948 film by powell and pressburger
recontextualize as images reminiscent of
the piles of clothes
from nazi concentration camps and the
scene itself
functions as a metaphor for how beauty
like
say the beauty of old fairy tales can
enchant us
into certain lines and ways of thinking
that may not
be in our interest here you have
constructed a vast
network of citation that reaches
elsewhere in the film
and outside of it the lines of that
network are
for the viewers to follow as they see
fit
del toro laces these references together
with camera work and editing to achieve
a narrative momentum
that's undeniable when you watch his
movies
it was the purpose of vidal like it is
the purpose of all
authoritarian regimes or patriarchal
moralistic
fairy tales to limit the number and
kinds of stories that can be told from a
set of facts
or events indeed limit it to one story
the only thing for it is to disobey
in old fairy tales the stories were
closed out and contained
by two words the end del toro's genius
is to use perhaps this most formulaic
genre of all
and disobey our expectations how it
should unfold
and how it should end the rebels capture
and kill vidal but
spain will continue under authoritarian
dictatorship
for 30 years ophelia is murdered but
completes her quest
and returns to the underground realm you
can read that as
a poetic ending to a sad story a happy
ending to a fairy tale or
ophelia's final choice of the story she
wants to tell
for and about herself of course
she doesn't have to choose at all no
single story
could contain her for even when she
returned
to the world of magic it has said
she left small traces of her time
on earth visible to those who know where
and
how to look
[Music]
hey everybody thanks for watching uh
pan's labyrinth has been one of my
favorite movies since i saw it in
theaters so this was just a blast to
make um if this is the type of content
that you don't think you're seeing
anywhere else on
on youtube or the internet you can
support this channel
by pledging to my patreon page right
here everything helps you guys have been
amazing
with that and it really is what makes
this channel possible and keeps it going
so i'm going to paris for the next
couple weeks
i might miss a week i'm talking to you
from the past right now but
if i don't see you next wednesday i'll
see you the wednesday after that